BUT FIRST, LAST WEEK GREAT
BRITIAN HELD PARLIAMENTARY
ELECTIONS, IT TURNS OUT THIS
LADY, THIS LADY SHE DOESN'T
RUN THE PLACE. SHE'S JUST
WATCHING THEIR DOGS.
SHE'S CORGI
SITTING FOR BRITAIN.
THAT'S ALL SHE'S DOING.
WELL, I'M SURE HER PAY IS
COMMENSURATE WITH HER TASKS.
ANYWAY ON THURSDAY BRITISH
VOTERS CHOSE THEIR NEXT PRIME
MINISTER, CONSERVATIVE AND
CURRENT PRIME MINISTER DAVID
CAMERON AN OXFORD EDUCATED
48-YEAR-OLD, THUMPED LABOR'S
ED MILIBAND, AN OXFORD EDUCATED
45-YEAR-OLD, BECAUSE HE
CAN'T MAKE UP THOSE THREE
YEARS.
THIS BEING A NATIONAL ELECTION
THE UK MEDIA WAS PULLING OUT ALL
THE STOPS, THEY HAD THEIR CREEPY
MADAME TUSSAUD VOTE
TALLY HOLOGRAMS, THEY HAD AN
UNREALISTICALLY POLITE
VIRTUAL PARLIAMENT THAT
DOUBLED AS THE  WORST SIM'S
EXPANSION PACK EVER AND THEY HAD
AN OPINION ROOM WHERE EACH
PUNDIT APPEARED TO HAVE
MISSED THEIR FLIGHT WHILE
ONE GUY BIDES HIS TIME WITH
SUDOKU, HE IS JUST BORED OUT OF
HIS MIND.
I JUST REALIZED, THE HOLOGRAMS,
THE VIRTUAL SETS, THE BRITISH
MEDIA HAS CONTRACTED A
DEVASTATING CASE OF
CNNITIS.
IT'S WHEN A NEWS ORGANIZATION
SPENDS A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
CREATING VISUALS AND SET PIECES
WHICH SERVE NO DISCERNIBLE
PURPOSE AND SHED NO
PERCEPTIBLE LIGHT AND ACTUALLY
DISTRACT YOU FROM WHAT IT WAS
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIND OUT.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING, NO ONE
CAN ACTUALLY CHALLENGE
THE MASTER.
>> GOOD MORNING FROM THE TOP
OF A BIG RED BUS THAT IS NOW
MAKING ITS WAY ACROSS
WESTMINSTER BRIDGE, ALISYN.
>> SO RICHARD, WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN NOW FOR THAT REFERENDUM
FOR BRITAIN
LEAVING THE EU?
>> ALISYN, I CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT.
HAVE A LOOK AT THAT, AS A
MILLION DOLLAR SHOT, LOOK AT
THAT, RIGHT UP THE RIVER
THAMES, THE LONDON EYE.
>> Jon: CAMEROTA ASKED YOU A
REAL QUESTION, YOU POINTED TO A
[BLEEP] FERRIS WHEEL.
THAT IS WHAT A SIX-YEAR-OLD
DOES.
I SEE A WHEEL, IT IS NICE,
IT SPINS AROUND.
WELL, BRITAIN'S MEDIA
COULDN'T MATCH US WITH WIDE
EYED NONSENSE THEY DID
COMPARE WITH US IN ONE
ARENA.
>> THE POLLS WERE COMPLETELY
WRONG.
ALL THE ADVANCED POLLS
WERE VERY WRONG.
THE REAL SHOT CAME AT 10
P.M. LONDON TIME WHEN THE
EXIT POLL WAS ANNOUNCED.
>> Jon: ISN'T THAT WHY WE HAVE
ELECTIONS?
TO TEST THE STRENGTH AND
COMPETENCE OF OUR POLLS?
THE REAL WINNER TONIGHT WAS
OUR POLLING SAFEGUARD
SYSTEM.
THE ELECTION.
SO DESPITE ALL PREDICTIONS,
CAMERON'S CONSERVATIVE SWEPT
TO AN OUTRIGHT MAJORITY.
THEIR MESSAGE MUST HAVE
REALLY CLICKED WITH VOTERS.
>> THE CONSERVATIVES CAN
ACTUALLY GOVERN THE WAY THEY
WANT TO.
>> GET RID OF THE DEFICIT.
>> AUSTERITY MEASURES REALLY
HITTING THOSE LOWER ON THE
ECONOMIC SCALE.
>> VERY LARGE CUTS TO THE
WELFARE STATE.
>> REPEAL TONY BLAIR'S BAN
ON HUNTING WITH DOGS.
>> Jon: WHAT A POPULAR
MESSAGE, A HEADY MIX OF
GRINDING AUSTERITY AND THE
KILLING OF SMALL FURY
ANIMALS.
I ALMOST HATE TO SAY THIS
BUT LEAVE FOX ALONE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
FOX NEVER HURT ANYBODY.
(LAUGHTER)
ANYWAY THOSE POLICIES SOUND
LIKE STUFF BRITISH PEOPLE
WOULD HATE.
HOW DOES LABOUR NOT WALK
AWAY WITH THIS ELECTION?
>> ED MILIBAND HAD PRETTY
DISMAL RATINGS WHEN IT CAME
TO LEADERSHIP.
THE VOTERS DIDN'T REALLY SEE
HIM AS PRIME MINISTERIAL.
>> 40% THOUGHT YOU WERE
WEIRD.
>> THEY SEE YOU AS --
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY?
PEOPLE I THINK THOUGHT --
>> THAT LADY IN THE BACK, IS
THAT A MAN, OH RIGHT, SORRY
ABOUT THAT, AND YOU'VE GOT A
BEARD SO YOU'RE CLEARLY A MAN,
YEAH.
>> Jon: WHAT!
SO THE LABOUR LEADER APPEARS
TO BE THE LOVE CHILD OF JOE
BIDEN AND DAVID BRENT -- SO
WHAT?
STILL, THE ELECTION WAS
MILIBAND'S TO LOSE.
I MEAN UNLESS THERE WAS SOME
UNUNFORTUNATE
IMAGE CRYSTALLIZING
INCIDENT.
>> AND IN THAT LABOUR
CAMPAIGN SYMBOLIZED BY
MILIBAND BREAKING ONE OF THE
BASIC RULES OF POLITICS,
DON'T EAT A BACON SANDWICH
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERAS.
THE TORY SUPPORTING PRESS
JUMPED ON THE IMAGE,
MILIBAND WAS NOT JUST A
FREE-SPENDING LABOURITE, HE
JUST DIDN'T LOOK LIKE A
PRIME MINISTER.
>> Jon: THAT'S IT?
HE ATE A BACON SANDWICH.
IN OUR COUNTRY YOU ARE NOT
EVEN CONSIDERED A VIABLE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
UNTIL YOU HAVE BEEN
PHOTOGRAPHED DEEP THROATING
AS MUCH OF A PIG AS WILL NOT
COMPLETELY BLOCK YOUR LARYNX.
IF THE BRITISH PRESS WENT ALL
IN ON ED'S LUNCH, I CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE WHAT THEIR VERSION
OF THE DAILY SHOW MUST HAVE
DONE.
>> HEY!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HEY, LOOK AT THIS GUY.
LOOK AT THIS [BLEEP],
[BLEEP], ED MILIBAND.
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT ARE YOU DOING SHOVING A
BACON BUTTY IN YOUR GOB
WITH YOUR HANDS LIKE SOME
KIND OF UTENSIL-LESS
GUTTERSNIPE, YOU EVER HEARD
OF SILVERWARE? YOU NEVER READ
YOUR DEBRETT'S GUIDE TO
ETIQUETTE WITH MODERN [BLEEP]
MANNERS?
WHAT'S THIS, MY FRIEND? THIS IS
BOLLOCKS, YOU BELLOW STAIRS
TOSS POT, IF YOU ARE FEELING
PECKISH, YOU POP THAT SANDWICH
ON A [BLEEP]
PLATE, YOU GET A KNIFE AND FORK
YOU UPPITY PIECE OF [BLEEP]!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: THAT WAS WEIRD.
WOW, THEIR DAILY
SHOW HOST IS ALMOST THE OPPOSITE
OF OURS WHERE I WOULD
NORMALLY BE UPSET WITH
SOMEONE EATING WITH A KNIFE
AND FORK AND YET THEIR DAILY
SHOW HOST, AN YET WE BOTH
TALK WITH THE SAME ACCENT.
THE ELECTION HAS LEFT THE UK
MORE STARKLY DIVIDED THAN EVER.
THE LEFT-LEANING SCOTTISH
NATIONALISTS SWEPT THE NORTH,
CONSERVATIVES DOMINATE THE
SOUTH, AND THEY AGREE ON
ALMOST NOTHING, WELL ALMOST
NOTHING.
>> THE SCOTTISH NATIONAL
PARTY IS THE VERY SAME PARTY
THAT WAS PUSHING FOR A
BREAKUP OF THE UNITED
KINGDOM AND FOR SCOTTISH
INDEPENDENCE.
>> DAVID CAMERON'S PROMISE
THAT THERE WOULD BE A
REFERENDUM WHERE BRITAIN
WOULD GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE TO LEAVE THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
>> SO YOU COULD HAVE BRITAIN
LEAVING THE EUROPEAN UNION,
SCOTLAND LEAVING THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
>> Jon: SLYTHERIN LEAVING
HOGWARTS.
DOWNSTAIRS LEAVING UPSTAIRS,
DOWNTON LEAVING ABBEY.
DOCTOR LEAVING WHO, EVERYONE IN
BRITAIN IS PRO SECESSION,
THEY JUST CAN'T AGREE ON
WHAT TO SECEDE FROM.
LET'S JUST DO IT, YOU KNOW WHAT,
LET'S JUST --
ENGLISH DITCHES EUROPE.
SCOTLAND DIVORCES ENGLAND.
WALES AND IRELAND SPLIT OFF
AND FRAGMENT, NORTHUMBRIA
AND EAST ANGLIA SECEDE.
THE ANCIENT KINGDOMS OF MERCIA
AND SUSSEX REASSERT THEIR
RIGHTS, OXFORD AND
CAMBRIDGE GO TO WAR.
LONDINIUM SEIZES THE BANKS,
THAT WEIRD STONEHENGE THING
COMES TO LIFE AND THE DRUIDS
START THEIR OWN THING,
TATTOO TRIBAL WAR LORDS CLASH IN
PETTY SQUABBLES, UNTIL THE
ONCE AND FUTURE KING ARTHUR
PULLS EXCALIBUR FROM
THE STONE AND ONCE AGAIN
UNITES ALL BRITAINS AGAINST
THE SAXON HORDE BUT BY THEN
IT'S TIME FOR THE NEXT WORLD
CUP AND NO ONE GIVES A
[BLEEP] ABOUT POLITICS